علماء كثر امضوا حياتهم بين الفقر
والتهميش وربما لم تذكر انجازاتهم الا بعد
سنوات طوال لكن العالم الامريكي جيمس
سايمونز بين هؤلاء وجد لنفسه مكانا بين
ملياردياريه العصر وجمع نحو 28 مليار
دولار فما سر هذه الثروه ولد جيمس هاريس
في ولايه ماسه الامريكيه عام
1938 حيث عمل والده هناك بتصنيع الاحذيه
فيما عمل هو عندما كان في الرابعه عشره من
عمره في مخزن لمستلزمات الحدائق لكنه كان
كثيرا نسيان فتم تحويله لكناس ارضيات ما
جعله محطه سخريه من زملائه بالعمل خصوصا
عندما كان يقول لهم انه يعتزم الالتحاق
بمعهد ماسه
للتكنولوجيا في عام
1955 قبل بمعهد ماسه وحصل على
ثم واصل دراسته وحاز على الدكتوراه من
جامعه كاليفورنيا وهو لا يزال في سن
الثالثه والعشرين في عام
1964 وبسبب موهبته بابتكار الخوارزميات
عين سايمونز بمعهد التحليلات الدفاعيه
كمحلل للشفرات كما قام بتدريس الرياضيات
بمعهد
ماسهرت بين عامي
1964 و
1968 قبل ان يتم تعيينه رئيسا لقسم
الرياضيات بجامعه حيث طور مع عالم
الرياضيات شينج شين شارن قياسات هندسيه
مهمه بالرياضيات وبنظريه الحقل الكمومي
وفيزياء الماده المكثفه في عام
1978 ادرك سايمونز ان بامكانه تحليل
البيانات الماليه باستخدام النماذج
الرياضيه فاستثمر خبراته في تاسيس
لاداره صناديق التحوط وضم سايمونز اليه
عددا من علماء الرياضيات وخبراء نمذجه
البيانات وفك الشفرات فحققت الشركه نجاحا
كبيرا قبل ان يغير اسمها الى تكنولوجيز
انما صندوق ميداليه
من 66 مليون دولار الى مليارين و400 مليون
دولار بين عامي
1993 و2000 فيما وصل الى عشره مليارات في
عام 2010 وهي النقطه الزمنيه التي فكر
فيها سايمونز بالاستقاله من منصبه كرئيس
تنفيذي للشركه في عام 2009 لكنه بقي رئيس
مجلس الاداره الان يتربع جيمس سايموز الذي
كان زملائه يسخرون من طموحاته على عرش
ثروه تقدر بنحو 28 مليارا ومئه مليون
دولار وتدير شركته نحو 50 مليارا فيما بات
يعرف بانه ملك الكم ورائد التداول الكمي
[موسيقى]